[Musique]
bonjour nicole gnesotto bonjour et merci
de nous accorder cet entretien peut-être
professeurs du conservatoire national
des arts et métiers et titulaire de la
chaire sur l'union européenne alors
l'europe c'est souvent presque toujours
construites à travers les crises vous
allez nous dire si cette pandémie va lui
permettre de faire sa révolution tout a
plutôt mal commencé on s'est replié sur
nous mêmes on a vu renaître les
frontières la solidarité n'était pas au
rendez vous comme ans au fond vous juger
la réaction de l'europe au tout début de
la crise oui vous avez raison au tout
début l'europe n'existe pas les
institutions sont absentés des états
membres qui se divise il ya deux raisons
je crois premièrement l'union européenne
elle n'est pas faite pour gérer les
crises son adn est telle qu'elle a été
créée dans les années 50 c'est le temps
long de la négociation en temps de paix
et donc l'union européenne ce qu'elle
sait faire c'est négocier prendre son
temps pour arriver à un consensus et
donc l'union européenne les institutions
européennes se sont retrouvés
complètement prise au dépourvu devant la
rapidité de la contagion ça c'est la
première réponse la deuxième réponse
c'est que dans la gestion du risque de
mort l'union européenne n'est surtout
pas compétente c'est-à-dire là aussi
depuis le début les états membres ont
tout fait pour garder leur souveraineté
sur toutes les questions qu'ils
appliquent la vie et la mort des
citoyens c'est à dire la défense et la
santé c'est pour ça que la santé n'est
pas encore aujourd'hui dans les
compétences de l'union et les états
membres ont fait ce qu'ils
interdiction de faire depuis toujours
ils ont remis les frontières très vite
en ordre dispersé ils ont envoyé sur les
roses les fameux critères de maastricht
c'est à dire on doit pas avoir un
déficit de plus de 3% une dette de plus
de 60% du pib ils ont fait valser tous à
l'exemple dépenser sans compter
quoiqu'il en côte a dit notre président
et et pendant ce temps là la commission
perdait son latin si je puis dire
finalement elle a très vite réagi et
elle a décidé d'annuler ce que les états
avaient
annulé eux-mêmes précédemment et petit à
petit donc les institutions et les états
ont retrouvé une espèce de voie moyenne
et la commission a commencé à annoncer
des plans de relance et comme en 2008 la
banque centrale européenne a eu un rôle
important
assez vite finalement en rachetant en
rachetant de la dette sur les marchés va
jouer au oui/non la banque centrale a
commencé par faire une énorme erreur
premières déclarations de madame lagarde
a dit oh là là c'est une affaire que les
états doivent gérer le jour même les
bourses françaises ont atteint leur
niveau historique le plus bas et elle
s'est très vite reprise elle a compris
que la banque centrale devait être un
acteur majeur mais ça n'a pas été comme
2008 ça n'a pas été le réflexe immédiat
de de la banque centrale après la banque
a effectivement décidé un premier plan
de relance de maintenant 750 milliards
d'euros mais qui est un plan de relance
traditionnel c'est-à-dire on prête aux
états et ensuite ils doivent rembourser
selon des modalités classiques
traditionnels comment vous comprenez
cette comparaison morbide qui s'est tenu
entre la france et l'allemagne pendant
pratiquement toute la crise où chacun
comptait ses morts ce nom son nombre de
respirateurs son nombre de lits de
réanimation son stock de masques ce
couple franco allemand s'est beaucoup
regardez vous avez raison on avait le
regard
rivé outre-rhin est aussi
à rome mais ça c'était la presse
pardonnez moi où l'opinion publique mais
je crois que les gouvernements n'ont pas
eu du tout cette attitude mais c'est
vrai
que la france a commencé à cafouiller
beaucoup plus que les allemands et que
donc la comparaison avec l'allemagne est
devenue en france une espèce de test du
niveau de puissance française et
beaucoup de vos confrères de beaucoup de
gens ont pensé que la france était en
train de devenir un pays du sud
d'ailleurs comme d'italie un pays des
classes est alors que l'allemagne avait
tous les masses tout des tests mais on a
réussi à parler d'une seule voix avec
l'allemagne et ça c'était de nouveau
emmanuel macron angela merkel qui décide
de tenir une conférence de presse
commune et qui annoncent un accord au
moins à 2 si ce n'est à 27 par la suite
sur la possibilité au fond de s'endetter
collectivement pour aider des régions
dans les pays en difficulté en quoi est
ce un tournant précisément d'abord il
faut se souvenir que cette fusion même
plus un couple c'est une fusion franco
allemande elle intervient après deux ans
de crispation et de crise dans le couple
franco allemand
très sévère c'était totalement
inattendue sur ce fonds un peu difficile
qu'il y ait comme ça une entente franco
allemande alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé d'abord sur le contenu de l'accord
ge il ya une vraie révolution je crois
pour dire les choses simplement en gros
il y aura un paquet de 1700 milliards
1800 milliards d'euros là dessus il ya
mille milliards qui sont le budget
normal de l'union et puis 750 milliards
en plus et sur ses 750 milliards il y
aura une partie qu'ils seront et ça
c'est la première évolution des dons les
cadeaux qui seront donnés gratuitement
aux pays qui en ont le plus besoin et ce
seront l'italie et l'espagne
essentiellement sans qu'il y ait des
compensations pour les autres et la
deuxième révolution c'est que pour le
reste de l'argent je crois que c'est à
peu près l'équivalent de 500 milliards
la commission européenne c'est-à-dire
une institution fédérale
va emprunter directement sur les marchés
c'est à dire que tout le monde y compris
l'allemagne va être solidaire de ses
emprunts donc on en prend 1 500
milliards sur 30 ans tout le monde va
les rembourser et pas seulement l'italie
et l'espagne pas seulement les pays qui
vont les recevoir pour l'instant c'est
ce que certains pays n'acceptent pas ce
qui est en négociation en particulier
les quatre qu'on appelle les frigos ou
les vertueux où les radins où les radins
qui sont le pays bas le danemark
l'autriche et la suède comment vous
expliquez que le soir même de l'annoncé
de l'accord par le couple franco
allemand ça fait la une partout en
allemagne médias radio télé presse
écrite et pas en france
c'est vrai la première raison c'est que
c'est un tournant historique
qui est quand même dû à la chancelière
il se met au niveau de cole adenauer
schmitt il il d'annoncer cet accord
comme étant au départ une proposition
fort et elle savait ça l'est mais ça
fait c'est dans la tradition de la
vision française alors que du côté
allemand c'est une révolution et ça sauf
l'europe c'est-à-dire tout seul la
france pouvait lui proposer c'était bien
mais ça ne servait à rien à partir du
moment où madame merkel rentrer dans ce
jeu c'est elle qui devient le héros de
la faire la deuxième raison c'est que
bon c'est un accord compliqué très
complexe à mettre en oeuvre dans le
détail
et c'est un accord qui suit les
objectifs
représente un saut en avant vraiment
dans l'intégration fédéral le
fédéralisme est un mot qui en france
fait hurler dans les chaumières ça n'est
pas populaire et donc je crains que le
une partie du silence français viennent
de de la réflexion suivante c'est à dire
c'est formidable on a un accord on a
même un saut en avant dans l'intégration
c'est génial il faut surtout pas le dire
et ça je pense que c'est inquiétant
parce que si on pense qu'on peut faire
de l'intégration européenne
en catimini c'est vraiment se réserver
des mauvaises surprises pour l'avenir
pourquoi la chancelière merkel signent
cet accord qu est ce qui la pousse alors
qu'elle termine son mandat
quel est au firmament dans les sondages
qu'est ce qui la pousse à faire ça c'est
une raison
d'histoire autrement dit cette femme
elle incarne une partie de l'histoire
européenne qu'elle ne veut pas voir
venir et donc à chaque fois qu'il ya un
moment historique elle a le bon réflexe
c'est vraiment un homme d'état
exceptionnelle tant qu elle le fait pour
l'histoire elle le fait tous les soirs
ses propres intérêts alors d'après la
deuxième question c'est que l appareil
beaucoup d'émotion mais la vraie raison
est la raison est très simple c'est
qu'on a beau dire que l'allemagne est le
pays le plus internationalisé avec un
commerce avec la chine extraordinaire ce
terrain mais quand même plus de 50% du
marché des exportations européennes
c'est le marché européen elle a besoin
d'un marché qui soit à la fois prospère
bien régulé et pas en crise donc
l'intérêt de l'allemagne en tant que
grosse entreprise est bien c'est que le
marché reste un marché
porteur et puis une troisième raison je
crois qui tient aussi à son histoire
personnelle elle a bien vu que l'extrême
droite monte un peu partout en europe
qu'en allemagne l'extrême droite fait
quand même 12% au bundestag et je crois
qu'elle s'est dit que si on ne sauve pas
l'europe c'est à dire si on donne raison
aux nationalise alors la démocratie est
en danger vous pensez que le peuple
allemand comprends cette décision il ya
eu quand même des critiques en allemagne
est-ce que ce tournant historique là les
allemands vont l'accompagner c'est toute
la question est ce que cette révolution
européenne
engage toute l'allemagne où est-ce que
c'est l'héritage personnelle de madame
mais c'est vraiment l'énigme l'enigma
fun du à venir savez le personnel c'est
un accord qui est susceptible de
réconcilier les européens avec l'europe
c'est un accord qui peut avoir une heure
une portée politique profonde et se
ressentir comme un infime ans d'union
les premiers euros
n'arriveront dans la poche des des
droits des chômeurs soit des entreprises
en difficulté pas avant l'été 2000 21 ah
oui autrement dit il y aurait pas tel
degré un tel retard entre les annonces
positives qui sont exceptionnelles et la
réalité de la mise en oeuvre qui sera
importante
qui sera tardive qu'on peut vraiment
redouté que cette période de latence
suscite malgré tout beaucoup de mauvaise
humeur des gens et que du coup de
nouveau des mouvements anti européens
trouvent matière à prospérer comment
vous la voyez vous la suite quels sont
les scénarios d'avenir possible pour
cette europe d'après coville 19
ça c'est la question à 1000 francs moi
je crois que ce qu'on vient de voir est
très important mais ne suffit pas on
peut dire qu'il ya trois scénarios il ya
le scénario de la restauration c'est à
dire on passe la crise ont fait en sorte
d'aider des entreprises en faillite ou
le sommaire en difficulté et après une
fois que tout ça est passé dans un angle
deux ans on revient à l'europe d'avancer
problème astri l'écriture et astrid les
trois pôles les 3 % et 30 % que ce texte
est rare et on essaye d'avoir de la
croissance par des réformes
structurelles c'est à dire une austérité
budgétaire
c'est le plus facile c'est la répétition
du même on vous sait faire moi je pense
que ce serait une catastrophe
mais c'est quand même le scénario
politique
sinon le plus probable en tout cas un
des plus probable parce que ça
correspond à ce que les institutions
safer
deuxième scénario on n'arrive pas à
résorber la crise c'est-à-dire le nombre
de faillites de chômeurs atteint des
proportions tellement spectaculaire que
l'éluder population se révolte dans des
élections diverses et variées et à ce
moment là l'europe se défait c'est pas
le scénario le plus probable mais c'est
pas un scénario impensable loin de là
loin de là et le troisième scénario
c'est effectivement le scénario de
masques lui que je préfère de la
''refondation'' qu'est ce que vous
appelez refondations alors sur les
aspects sanitaires je suis contre l'idée
de mettre la santé dans les compétences
de l'union européenne c'est-à-dire de
l'enlever aux états membres parce
qu'encore une fois il ya un risque de
mort pour les sites web donc moi je
pense que la santé doit de rester
nationale en revanche moi je suis pour
la création d'une banque centrale
européenne sanitaire qui tous les jours
tous les jours achète des thèses des
vaccins des masses des médicaments du
doliprane enfin tout ce qu'il faut et
fasse des stops pour le jour où on
puisse déjà avoir quelque chose en
commun a dit staff est un élément
d'intégration de membres fondation je
crois que l'essentiel de la refondation
serait d'en faire enfin pour une fois
que le politiques l'emportent sur le
marché moi je suis pour une europe de la
solidarité politique avec des devoirs et
des sanctions quand on ne la respecte
pas et pour faire cette refondation vous
appelez de vos voeux nicole bouteau
est-ce qu'on a les hommes politiques les
incarnations politiques en europe qui
puisse la rendant possible je crois que
le leurs fondations politiques elle sera
grandement fonction de la peur qu auront
des dirigeants européens de voir tout
cela
s'effilocher et de voir surtout les
extrêmes droites monte un peu partout
quand on voit que lui la croissance
augmente plus les inégalités augmentent
on se dit que les hommes d'état
aujourd'hui qui nous gouvernent n'ont
pas tiré les leçons je dis aujourd'hui
il ne suffit pas de dire on va faire de
la croissance comme ça le surplus on va
leur distribuer ça c'était vrai avant
dans le capitalisme damman et
aujourd'hui senna verse plus on fait de
la croissance
plus on augmente les inégalités
donc ce n'est pas le surplus de la
croissance qui va réduire les inégalités
c'est une politique volontariste de
réduction des inégalités
eh bien merci ni comme l'y autorise
aussi beaucoup
[Musique]